Vince Cantu runs Moses roses a San
Antonio Texas bar that's on the site of
the famous 1836 battle memorialized on
the big screen many times I've been
living under the threat of MN domain for
six years
the Alamo trust a non-profit that
manages the site wants to expand the
Alamo Museum which would include
building a theater and a civil rights
exhibit where Moses roses currently
stands
the San Antonio city council voted in
late January to authorize the use of
eminent domain which would allow the
city to condemn and acquire the property
to hand to the Alamo trust if Cantu
doesn't take their state-backed offer
the bad faith negotiation that
they you know said they had to have
before they would start imminent domain
Texan is small government and
um and fiercely independent it's
stupidly ironic completely on Texan
[Music]